wait so okay so if you were at the end
now so then what's the thing you'd say
after I would
exit cuz now we're friendly we go oh
that was fun that was good okay so we're
going to pretend you're not here for a
second okay pretend that okay M Mike
just left and we take we take we're
going to leave them on but we take these
off mhm door shuts I have to go to the
bathroom so do I you always have to go
to the that's what we would first say
okay but then let's say it's after that
and we're just sitting here okay get a
quick snack yes you guys get snacks I'm
trying to get us past that to the part
where we talk about Mike biglia okay
okay oh wow what you guys think well I
really liked him because he had a team
Sona mug and he had questions for us
just that's why I really liked it
because of that he had me at the
beginning yeah well I already was a huge
fan but being in room with the person
he's so smiley and that makes you feel
so good I loved him I you loved him I
loved him and I'll say I don't say take
care I'm saying and I loved him oh
that's nice I'm a big fan and I really
admire his body of work uh and I think
he's a true uh comedic artist however uh
he read personal texts between me and
him without my permission and that felt
like a violation that felt like and now
I'm supposed to text him again and trust
him when I'm in Brooklyn no how am I how
am I supposed to trust him now that he
doesn't then go on Stern or some other
hey guys what's going on I'm back
you killed it oh thank you so
much I thought it was fun I loved it
loved it and the uh the text thing was
fantastic did you like that cuz I I was
going to maybe ask you before but I
thought it be more spontaneous in the
moment no you don't need to ask all
right thanks thanks you guys app it so
anyway remove the text part cuz I cuz I
come off like cranking out the paws it
just sound like a press sorry I left my
notes did you say that you didn't like
the text part you like the text part I
said it was I would I wish there was
more and I said double it have it play
twice in one podcast yeah so no kill her
kill her but you're going for sure now
right do you mind if I walk you out and
then lock the door yeah no absolutely
just going to shut the door here we go
and then and then I'm locking it and
double bolting it now I want to change
my opinion he's a little pushy he's
pushy and he keeps coming in back in
wait a minute someone got a hydraulic
[Laughter]
drill hey guys Jesus I left my glasses
you weren't even wearing glasses I know
but I just I thought I should start
that's a
$35,000 door
oh now I know how you really
feel budha you demanded I call you
Buddha in the interview that's the part
I left out I told you if you could
mention in that I'm a comedy Buddha and
that you all feel that way I'd really
appreciate it and you'd get $500 worth
of coffee pods
well they never showed up thanks for
nothing
ladies and gentlemen you just
heard real
improvisation none of this was planned
and yet it
happened um
uh not a fan not a fan of you don't like
you don't like Sona I'm okay on Adam
we're getting you a team Adam mug by the
way he's okay on you we're getting
let's get a mug let's let's get a m not
mentioned let's get let's get one mug
made that says Matt
B Matt gorley sorry Matt gorley uh and
Mike biglia are okay with uh with uh
Adam Sach what about that that's that's
gonna sell that's going to be our
biggest seller yeah fill full of C-
pods
Cobra Cobra bigs pods so seriously
uh I'm R off your tongue for can you for
real do you or do you not want to
purchase Cobra bigs pods do not do not
but let me ask you again do not let me
phrase it let me give you this get back
in here one bean
one leave the room Cobra big security
there's no security here Cobra big B
there's no security get him
out are you putting the door back on or
are you taking it off I game through the
ceiling oh my God what Happ you came to
the ceiling with Rip Taylor energy I
came to the
ceiling he's got
[Music]
confetti